[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo de América edición nocturna
Para eso hoy nos acompaña nuestro
periodista Jorge Hurtado Jorge buenas
noches bienvenido y empecemos con el
gran tema del momento en materia
económica y es el acuerdo entre China y
Arabia Saudita un acuerdo de asociación
estratégica En qué consiste bueno el rey
Saudita y el presidente chino firmaron
acuerdos que según reportes
independientes ascienden a más de 30.000
millones de dólares esta Alianza
representa el máximo nivel de confianza
que otorga el gigante asiático a otro
país en cuestión de alianzas
Internacionales y permite incluso a
China ganar influencia en la región
árabe una movida que sin duda está
inquietando a Washington porque hay otro
país que ahora quiere arrancarle el
puesto como el principal socio comercial
del Golfo Pérsico los seis puntos del
acuerdo son parte de un plan alineado
con la visión 2030 de Arabia Saudita que
busca a que esa economía deje de
depender del petróleo y la iniciativa la
franja y la ruta que es parte de China
se firmaron memorándose entendimientos
en temas como energía de hidrógeno
energía solar inversiones indirectas y
también en el sector inmobiliario la
agencia de prensa oficial saudí dijo que
el comercio binacional ascendió a 80 mil
millones de dólares en 2021 y a 27 mil
millones de dólares en el tercer
trimestre de 2022 bueno Jorge ahora le
propongo que cambiemos de tema porque el
banco de Rusia advirtió sobre los
efectos que están teniendo las sanciones
contra El crudo que exportamos bueno
según el emisor la imposición de un
precio tope al crudo ruso podría
disminuir significativamente la
actividad económica en Rusia el banco
destacó en un comunicado el embargo a la
exportación por mar del crudo Ruso y su
derivados a Europa y la imposición de un
precio tope al petróleo ruso impuesto
por la Unión Europea y los países del g7
y también Australia Vladimir Putin ya ha
dicho que petroleras rusas no firmarán
contratos en los que figuren precios
regulados o techos a los precios y ahora
vamos a noticias de nuestro continente
América porque en Argentina
es viar la carga para los trabajadores
que pagan un impuesto sobre el salario
En qué consiste esto Bueno en ese país
se anunció una modificación que
beneficia a los trabajadores que pagan
este denominado impuesto a las ganancias
un tributo que se aplica sobre los
ingresos salariales de estos de salarios
medios o altos según Fuentes oficiales
más de 300.000 trabajadores dejarán de
pagar el tributo desde el primero de
enero de 2023 esto Gracias a una
modificación al alza en el piso mínimo
de salario a partir del cual se debe
pagar el impuesto la medida era un
reclamo de los sindicatos Dado que los
ajustes salariales al alza negociados ya
por los gremios permiten que los
salarios aumenten pero a la vez hacen
que más trabajadores tengan que pagar el
impuesto a las ganancias Y explícanos
por qué el gobierno de Estados Unidos
bloqueó la compra de activision por
parte de Microsoft bueno la oferta de
compra era por 69 mil millones de
dólares de parte del gigante tecnológico
Microsoft esta iba a convertirse en la
mayor operación de la historia en el
sector de los videojuegos activision El
fabricante de juegos como Call of Duty y
Microsoft es propietaria del famoso Xbox
la decisión la tomó la Comisión Federal
de comercio de Estados Unidos encargada
de velar por el cumplimiento de la ley
antimonopolio en ese país la comisión
ahora argumenta que Microsoft tiene un
historial de compra de valiosos
productores de videojuegos para suprimir
la competencia en ese sector las
acciones de Microsoft y también de
activision cayeron al conocerse la
denuncia de la comisión y hay otra
noticia en Europa porque la comisión
europea le pidió a plataformas digitales
de alojamiento y de transporte que
recauden el impuesto del IVA como Cuáles
aplicaciones se verían afectadas bueno
como por ejemplo airbnb y también la de
transporte Uber El Ejecutivo comunitario
también propone crear un sistema de
información a tiempo real para compras
transfronterizas dentro de la Unión
Europea a través de obligatoria de
facturas electrónicas con el objetivo de
reducir el fraude de IVA en este tipo de
operaciones estas propuestas junto con
la creación de un portal único de IVA
para el registro de aquellas empresas
que venden sus productos en más de un
estado miembro forman parte del paquete
de propuestas de Bruselas para adaptar
el sistema del IVA a la era digital con
esto las autoridades comunitarias
pretenden recaudar hasta 18.000 millones
de euros al año en la próxima década
bueno y antes de terminar la sección
económica cuénteme qué está pasando con
la huelga que están haciendo los
periodistas del diario estadounidense el
New York Times bueno inconforme con las
negociaciones contractuales que llevan
meses en ese periódico reporteros
Editores fotógrafos y otros trabajadores
se manifestaron frente a las oficinas
del Time mientras el periódico recurría
a personal internacional o a otros
periodistas que no estuvieran sindicados
para distribuir contenido a sus más de 9
millones de suscriptores en Estados
Unidos y el mundo se discuten temas como
los salarios
políticas de trabajo a distancia y
también el sistema el sistema de
evaluación de empleados de la empresa
que según el sindicato es vulnerable a
los prejuicios raciales el sindicato
alega que los empleados merecen una
mejor compensación por su papel en
ayudar al Times a convertirse en una
historia de éxito en la industria de las
noticias el Time aumentó su base de
suscriptores en los últimos años y
proyectó un beneficio operativo ajustado
de entre 320 y 330 millones de dólares
para este año Jorge Gracias por estas
noticias económicas y volvemos en con
más Dentro de pocos minutos Nosotros
continuamos con el debate en el que mi
compañero Santiago López debatirá
Precisamente lo que está ocurriendo en
Perú